what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are jumping into Aquaman
rebirth with underworld what we're gonna
do for the next few weeks is actually
gonna kind of double up on these so that
we can get them up all the way to ground
earth which is actually looks pretty
amazing Justice League and in Aquaman
but but picking up with this one thing
to bear in mind is remember in the last
video that or less yeah last video that
we did we basically talked about how
Aquaman had been overthrown from
Atlantis that you had quorum wrath who
led a group called the deluge which was
really just like a terrorist cell but
core wrath was a leader of it and they
in turn overthrew Arthur curry and then
because of the fact of the various
people who serve under Arthur curry
served the throne and not really Aquaman
himself so like commander Merc
commander Merc himself was tasked with
killing Aquaman and supposedly
successfully did it you know basically
stabbed him to the back and so following
this is really been like a couple weeks
since corum wrath is taking power and at
this point he's consolidating his forces
together and things are kind of crazy
because what this does is this picks up
initially with the idea of the ninth
tribe well that's one of the cool things
about what Dan admits doing is there's a
lot of expansion that's going on with
the Atlanta Atlantean mythos in in DC
rebirth as a whole and it's really
really cool to see because what we end
up doing is is transitioning to the
ninth tried itself we end up having
Arthur curry who's still alive and well
as we would expect him to be it wouldn't
be much of an Aquaman title if he's dead
but he's basically sitting down here in
the ninth tried and what he tells us is
the ninth tried is it's almost like the
levels of health so to speak from from
Dante's Inferno from Dante's Divine
Comedy the ninth tried is the lowest
level and so that's basically for like
undesirables for mutants for people who
were deemed to be the lowest caste of
society but more so than that is for
people to hide out at and so what we end
up doing is kind of transitioning to a
second to a guy named volcko now volcko
is as he's been part of the alchemy
mythos for a while in new 52 he was the
one that essentially sparked like the
throne of Atlantis story where you ended
up having like the war of Atlantis where
you had Aquaman's brother who attacked
the surface world and that led to the
greatly huge conflict and so on and so
forth but he's a guy who's been in
Atlantis for a long long long time and
he knows a lot of things and he's one of
those where even if he's not liked by
everybody people know who he is and so
him showing up here and talking to
people is basically saying look we have
to strike while the iron's hot we have
to find a way to overthrow quorum wrath
the problem with this is that vocals
looked at it as a guy who will use
people for his own ends and so people
don't really trust him per se the other
half of this is that you have the crown
of thorns which surrounds Atlantis and
it uses very old magic magic that cannot
be a penetrator using like Ross
or anything like that and so for the
most part they're stuck down there not
only that because of the fact that corn
whereas people like you know his
leadership don't really venture down
into the ninth tried what they do is
they use the ninth tried to police
itself now for Arthur himself for
Aquaman he just kind of says well you
know I'm not who you think I am I'm just
some guy who's here and and he's
basically trying to stay under the radar
and so what this does is it switches
over to amnesty Bay for a for a minute
or two there's not a great big huge
thing but it does switch over to amnesty
Bay and you've got mera who's dealing
with the perceived death of her husband
and that's one of the important things
to bear in mind is that while Mara is
presented to us oftentimes in DC Comics
as a character who's pretty hardcore and
she is she's also a woman and she's also
a person who loves and she reacts to the
world accordingly and so it is cool to
basically humanize her in that regard to
say like this is a loving thinking
breathing human were not really a human
woman but like you know a woman with
human feelings and emotions and thoughts
and ideas she is as we would perceive
her to be a human as we think of a human
being and so the result is she functions
in all the same capacities and she
grieves just like any other wife who's
ever lost her husband and so in this
moment what Arthur starts doing is he
actually starts drawing on Batman this
is a genius idea
he starts drawing on the nature of
Batman it says well in Gotham City
Batman is more of a myth or not really a
myth but he's more of like a legend he's
a thing to be feared he's a symbol no
one knows who Batman is he uses fear he
uses an intimidation and he uses shock
in order to keep Gotham in line so I
will do that too
and so kind of operating in the ninth
tried kind of like this mini gotham city
of atlantis basically aquaman starts
using fear and he starts using shock in
order to get people to do what he wants
to do at the very least to back off and
to basically protect the various people
who were down there and what this starts
to do is it starts to build up this myth
of the aquaman that there's a person
down there that's protecting them now
the other half of this is that with warm
wrath beginning to kind of lose faith
and like the ability of the 9th tried to
to govern itself he in turn starts
tasking the drift with going down there
and wiping out mutants wherever he finds
and so what you end up having is like
this this chick named dolphin who
basically ends up fighting against some
of the drift some of the elite forces of
the Atlantean army and then in turn in
the middle of all that when the drift is
gonna kill them all you have Aquaman who
shows up and basically saves the day but
he ends up kind of grabbing the
attention of dolphin and then from there
she essentially seems to be smitten with
him that's really what kind of seems to
be going on now while all that's going
on what you have is volcko breaking or
kind of yeah
kind of breaking into the silent school
which is where like a lot of the magic
is taught in Atlantis and then using one
of their artifacts to essentially like
make a phone call to Mira and do the
best he can to tell her Aquaman's alive
he doesn't finish the sentence meirin
knows what he's saying and she says
aquaman is alive we have to go and find
him and so is it really really cool
moment here because from this point you
really start to get into like a lot of
the history of the Aquaman mythos with a
lot of different things that are going
on but a lot of the powers of areas
people possessed with Aquaman fighting
alongside dolphin she has
bioluminescence and what this basically
means is she can let off like an
extremely bright light they can
basically blind anybody in an immediate
vicinity but we'll also find out she can
control it in a more fine-tuned way
later on down the line for Mira's
character her idea is to try to break
through the crown of thorns and while
she does have the ability like control
water using a telekinetic ability more
or less she can't quite break through it
and that's something the quorum wrath
knows and that's why he doesn't stress
about it now at that point going forward
this is what we start to get into like
the real underbelly of Atlantis and it's
something that we don't usually see it
basically says there's this this whole
other segment you know you have Atlantis
way up there at the top you have like
the first try basically at the first
house and then way down here you've got
like little hiding rooms you've got
little shelters you've got like these
subsets of people who are trying to make
their way who are basically is kind of
struggling and and doing the best they
can under like this really crappy
circumstance essentially living in the
ghetto and when Aquaman goes to this
place alongside dolphin and meets with a
handful of these people the ragtag
barely making ends meet I mean they're
taking it day by day for Aquaman it's
the darkest of times for them it's
always been dark times so it's kind of
crazy to see like this this sort of
comparison between these two groups and
of course this basically ends up leading
to like cadaver one of the forces of a
guy named crushed showing up with a
purpose of like tracking down you know
these mutants and then tracking down
like the super quote-unquote The Legend
of Aquaman you know and then looking to
like secure him for his own ends because
crush believes he knows who it is which
is kind of cool because this this leads
to a really really interesting
conversation when Aquaman is brought
before trush Aquaman's first inclination
and even our first inclination to the
SEC he's a bad guy he's a mob boss but
but crushes whole stance is it's not so
clear-cut it's not so black and white we
live down here in a place where no one
cares the kings of old don't care what
we do because we were always considered
to be cast off we're undesirables but
you want to pretend like we don't exist
and so because you pretend like we don't
exist we do what whatever we have to do
in order to make ends meet is it any
wonder why we turn to crime and it makes
sense but at the end of the day Aquaman
kind of sees through that facade and
says no no
you can masquerade it how you want to
but you're a warlord like you you're
nothing more than just a petty warlord
using power to your own ends and just
try to hold on to that power as long as
you possibly can and so following this
crush says yeah you're kind of right
yeah basically that's kind of true but
it doesn't take away from what he said
before and that's kind of the
interesting thing about it now with
regards to doll for herself crush has
kind of been using her as bait and he
basically says he told Aquaman I know
exactly who you are well you can tell me
that you're not that you're not the king
of Atlantis that you're not Arthur curry
but I think you are because you look
like him now this is the important thing
to bear in mind this is the ninth try
and so while they are aware of the king
they don't have regular dealings with
him and that's why the initial
inclination and the initial question
might be but like it's the king of
Atlantis how do they not know what he
looks like well if they never meet him
how are they know what he looks like
what reason would they have to know what
he looks like he's just some disembodied
figure who exists up there somewhere
and occasionally the laws he passes will
affect him in some form or fashion I
guess basically yet so so with Dan
Abnett playing on that is it is a little
fast and loose but it does work and this
is where crush comes in because he
basically says I told you that girl was
gonna serve a purpose and the purpose is
she's not alone inside that inside that
that tank if you do not tell me who you
are if you do not confess to the fact
that you're Aquaman that giant beast is
gonna eat her and so it's kind of cool
to see because it's just kind of like
all right is he actually going to let
her die like is he actually going to let
this chick die ultimately of course
Aquaman doesn't using his ability to
talk to fish he basically calls the
thing off and that's an admission of
guilt because remember Aquaman is the
only person that has that power and so
because it's so unique he might as well
be walking around with giant purple
letters over his head saying I'm Aquaman
I'm the king of Atlantis and so in that
recognition and in doing that of course
he talks to the to the giant creature
they basically end up escaping and he
and dolphin end up running off and of
course crushed ends his guys after
Aquaman says capture him bring him back
to me and we can use him as bartering
power for king wrath in order to sort
out the things we want to sort out now
this is where the plot starts to thicken
and this is where Dan Abnett really
stands out as a great writer where we
look at all these different things that
are going on we look at quorum wrath you
basically seize power we look with
Aquaman who's in the knife try just
trying to make ends meet and trying to
be somewhat of a freedom fighter but not
return to his role as king and we look
at Mara who's trying to find a way or
for your husband what we end up doing is
picking up with the silent school these
people that like practice magic and what
they start doing is they start scheming
and they are saying well inevitably this
is gonna lead to a fight between Aquaman
and Corum wrath when he goes to take
back the throne
form laughs we're not just kneel and
just hand the throne to Aquaman
it's gonna be a bloody and fierce battle
and they may kill them both and if they
do well then the silent school should be
the ones to rise and basically like like
the widowhood should be the ones to rise
and should be the ones to lead and so
the question becomes well if we do that
then who's gonna be the leader and it's
like well then it'll be Mara like mayor
will be the one to take over everything
so it's it's really really cool because
now it turns into a kind of game of
thrones esque situation where everyone's
vying for power now following this we
switch back over to Volker and what
volcko is doing here is actually pretty
interesting volcko had been contacted by
a member a really er names like like on
Dean but a member of the the widowhood
basically saying like hey look I'm here
to guide you protect you to make sure
that you that whatever it is that you're
doing here
that you're your attempt to basically
find a way to take down this crown of
thorns by accessing the Trident of
Aquaman that you're not gonna die in the
process and so in this moment what is up
happening is is the two of them
basically access the catacombs which
goes into the Treasury
now the Treasury of Atlantis is where
the where the the the Trident of Aquaman
is currently stationed at the problem is
it's under lock and key like no one gets
in or out who's not supposed to be there
and so they're basically going through
the underbelly in order to work their
way up to the top the issue with this is
that it's all guarded by like people who
were formerly advisors to the various
kings of Atlantis and they go back a
long long ways this is a really really
cool moment here because what this does
is it says it like these people who end
up taking up this role do so willingly
that when the time comes when they pass
on they'll basically say like my spirit
will dwell here as a protector of the
underbelly in order to make sure no one
can sneak into the throne into the the
treasury room and steal things as it was
a huge honor for them to have the
problem with this is that if you want to
get past them you have to be able to
speak their name if you don't they will
kill you now volcko has been around for
a long time and so volcko knowing the
various names of these people allows him
and Ondine to basically make their way
through and to sneak past as it was it's
really kind of a cool moment here the
other half of this and really was kind
of going on is with mirrors inability to
break through the the crown of thorns
that's guarding Atlantis she goes as she
seeks out Aqualad I guess really tempest
if you want to call them that she goes
as you seeks out Garth now I am NOT the
most well-versed when it comes to Garth
I don't know a whole lot about his
character Garth was out of my wheelhouse
I never really cared about him like I
was ever really interested in him so I
never really had a reason to look into
him he was just kind of a character who
was there that you know I knew existed
but that was really about it
but with with Mirah going to him and and
seeing him for ate one of the things
that he reveals here at least is from
what Dan admits doing is one of these he
says is in the new 50
- here's originally just a ward of
Aquaman and that was really it and then
from there he was basically enrolled in
the silent school the problem with this
was that the leader of the silent school
had pushed him and another girl named
Saira as extremely hard and this led to
a lethal situation whereby Garza
performed an experiment and Saira had
died and so blaming the leader of the
silent school garthe left he basically
abandoned now he does remember a lot of
the magical properties a lot of the
magical principles and that came with
his time in the silent school but he
doesn't practice them anymore he's
basically left that part of his life
behind but Mira coming to him and saying
look you have to help here you're the
only one that can get me through this is
basically like his loyalty to Aquaman
and his loyalty to Atlantis and then
leaving and coming back in and trying to
help mirror as best he can as it was
kind of a cool little scenario here
because whether were there facing off
against these forces of of coram wrath
these forces of the silence school they
do the best they can and they hold their
own but in the middle of all this garthe
basically steals one of the amulets him
and Mira race off because they're being
outnumbered and then Attorney gives the
amulet and says this thing should let
you through but the problem is it's
damaged I don't know what's gonna happen
here and so it's a pretty dangerous game
and so again Jemmy back to Volkers again
is there's a lot happening here so Joey
back to volcko where he and Undine
basically go through and in again start
talking to these ghosts the further they
get in the older the ghosts get and the
older they get the more decayed they get
which means that volcko can't recognize
them and the exact scenario happens
where basically one of these ghosts pop
up and he has no idea who they are and
he keeps calling him by the wrong name
and he's just like run so they basically
end up taking off they basically just
flee for their life as fast as they can
now ultimately this leads to him just
kind of like running off a series of
names and then ultimately realizing like
he finally calls out the right name and
this one starts addressing him properly
and then actually starts talking to him
which is something that we haven't seen
before like from what volcko said
normally you can say their name and then
they'll just leave you know because it's
like okay you're allowed to be here
because you're of Atlantean heritage and
you know who we are and and so on and so
forth this one starts talking to him you
know like like Noel just kind of starts
talking to them they start having a
conversation and when they do know
basically leads into the treasure room
because the two of them are really
really good friends back in their
younger days but making their way to the
treasure room this basically leads them
to gathering the the Trident of Aquaman
which basically will give him the
ability to lower down the the shield now
from here because of the fact that like
Alpha had managed to make his escape
from crushed crush and turn reasons that
if he goes back to quorum ratha says hey
look here's everything that's going on
Aquaman is actually alive that
Korath will basically give him a pardon
or will put him in like total control of
like the ninth trident and then like
since the members of the drift down
there to enforce the authority of crush
but when he gets back up there and he
goes to commander merc the person who
originally killed aqua he says look I
need to talk to quorum wrath it's about
Arthur curry the dead King is actually
alive and like commander Mertz responses
of course he is and then in turn kills
crush and as soon as I saw that I was
like I knew it I knew that he didn't
kill Aquaman I knew there was no I knew
he had to be on the inside of it I knew
he had to be the reason why I alpha man
was still alive it's the only way you
can make it work now for mera once she
actually leaves the the ocean waters per
se and then goes directly inside of
Atlantis she immediately starts
suffocating and in reality I'm not sure
why I'm not really sure how Dan admits
making this work like she needs oxygen
to breathe and the reason why it's kind
of strange to me is because she goes
from water to water now there's a
barrier there but we don't know if part
of the magic and this this may be what
happened if part of the magic that was
imposed there is if someone left and
came in that wasn't supposed to that it
takes away their ability to breathe
underwater that seems to be the effect
that's going on here but we wouldn't
really know unless it was explicitly
stated it's really just kind of a
crapshoot but Mara basically starts
suffocating now at the same time what
you also have is kind of a cool thing
you've also got freedom fighters this is
kind of a cool little moment here
because when you have Aquaman sort of
addressing this whole thing that you
have the others this group called the
undercurrent with the rise of quorum
Rath who's not recognized as a
legitimate king there are those who
defected those who are still loyal to
Arthur curry and say we will continue to
fight and try to overthrow quorum wrath
and we'll do it in the name of Arthur
even though we believe he's dead and
it's kind of a cool thing because that's
how all these things happens right like
the one thing that dictators fear is
that someone will rise to power and take
them down
and so Aquaman joins the undercurrent
and in turn kind of gives us this this
interesting monologue where he says the
undercurrent are really nothing more
than just part and you know farmers with
pitchforks basically you know to quote
the quote the patriot they're not really
capable here what they need is they need
structure they need order they need
someone to transform them from
essentially like a militia into like an
ordered military force and that's what
Aquaman does he sits them down and says
we have to start working together and
what we're gonna do here is we're gonna
create an actual fighting force and then
what we're gonna do is we're going to
leave this fighting force directly
against quorum wrath we're gonna
overthrow his reign and then in turn
we're gonna take it Lantis back but
here's the kicker Aquaman does
not want to be king he does not want to
rule Atlantis and that's one of the
things that he was kind of learning when
he was spending time with dolphins is
that dolphin as a girl who can't talk
has to communicate they like hand
gestures and things like that and she
draws pictures of like the symbols of
the Justice League of Batman Superman
Wonder Woman and all command recognizes
those as he talks to himself and tries
to figure out what she's saying he comes
to the realization that Superman the
Batman Wonder Woman they're not kings
and queens verges heroes they're
protectors and what Aquaman came to
realize was that as king of Atlantis he
was ruling as a king but not ruling as a
leader that he was pretty he was
essentially ruling over what he saw he
wasn't ruling over what he didn't see
and all these people down here at the
bottom all these people in the 9th tried
in the 8th tried and these lower tribes
down here were all cast offs there were
people all command didn't care anything
about and so his stance is I don't want
to be a tried and true king like a king
like I was before I want to be a leader
I want to represent all of these people
these members of the 9th trying all
these cast-off people and that's a great
thing
because this is a veritable army this is
an untapped resource there are countless
people living down here in your
countless beings living down here who
have all felt left out who have all felt
walked all over who have felt like they
don't matter and then suddenly someone
comes along and says I was a king once
and I lost being a king and when I was
King what I failed to realize is how
much all of you mattered so fight with
me and we will overthrow the existing
establishment will cast off this false
King and I will represent all of you
guys accordingly there is nothing is
it's the one thing that Aquaman is able
to tap into here the one thing that can
change the tide of everything good or
bad it can make things worse or it can
make things better but the one thing
he's tapping into is hope hope can be
used as a weapon or it can be used as a
means to inspire people to greater
things but that's the cool moment your
Aquaman is feeding on the hope of those
who live down in the ninth tribe they're
looking for a better life and in turn
using the hope as a means to bring all
these people together to overthrow King
wrath but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rock or if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]